[Música]
la desaparición de los 43 estudiantes de
ayotzinapa fue un crimen de estado así
lo determinó un informe preliminar de la
comisión de la verdad en mexico el
documento también señala que no hay
indicios de que los jóvenes estén vivos
representantes y empresarios de colombia
y venezuela se reunieron en la ciudad
fronteriza de cúcuta se trata de un
primer acercamiento para intentar
reanudar las relaciones comerciales
entre ambas naciones así como la
reapertura de los puentes
internacionales tenemos reporte desde
caracas
la justicia estadounidense abre la
puerta para que el presunto atacante del
escritor salman rushdie sea investigado
por posibles delitos de odio esto luego
de que el joven de 24 años se declarara
inocente de los cargos de intento de
asesinato y agresión en segundo grado
hola bienvenidos a las noticias del
continente americano en france 24 los
saluda andrés meza muñoz
empezamos en mexico la comisión de la
verdad creada en 2018 determinó en un
informe preliminar que la desaparición
de los 43 estudiantes de ayotzinapa fue
un crimen de estado concluyó también que
autoridades federales y estatales de más
alto nivel fueron omisas y negligentes y
les acusó de alterar los hechos y las
circunstancias el documento menciona que
no hay indicios de que ninguno de los
estudiantes esté vivo lo que constituye
el nuevo capítulo en el caso de los
jóvenes que desaparecieron el 26 de
septiembre de 2014 cuando se dirigía a
la ciudad de méxico para participar de
una manifestación que en todo momento
las autoridades federales estatales y
municipales
tuvieron conocimiento de la movilización
de los estudiantes
desde la salida de la escuela normal
isidro burgos hasta su desaparición y
sus acciones
omisiones y participación
permitieron la desaparición y ejecución
de los estudiantes así como el homicidio
y otras seis personas
representantes gubernamentales y
empresarios de colombia y venezuela
llevaron a cabo una reunión en la ciudad
fronteriza de cúcuta un primer
acercamiento para restablecer sus
relaciones comerciales previamente desde
caracas nuestra corresponsal daniela
zambrano nos contaba los detalles de
dicho encuentro pero en cerca de 300
empresarios entre venezolanos y
colombianos que acudieron a este
encuentro en cúcuta allí no se habló de
una fecha específica para la reapertura
de la frontera entre colombia y
venezuela pero el ministro de comercio
de colombia dijo que sería pronto a
corto plazo pero que primero deberían
garantizarse condiciones en materia de
seguridad y también en materia
diplomática se habló incluso de crear un
pase especial para que los ciudadanos
puedan pasar de una forma más fácil de
un lado a otro y quien fue designado
como embajador de colombia en venezuela
hermano benedetti quien estuvo presente
en este foro habló incluso de
digitalizar lo que con la huella los
ciudadanos pudiesen pasar el ministro de
transporte de colombia también dijo que
los puentes fronterizos ya estaban
para poder ser reabiertos recordemos que
estos están cerrados desde hace siete
años había preocupación por el estado de
estos puentes por el lado venezolano se
habló además en este foro de hacer una
zona económica de crear una zona
económica
diferencial con excepción de impuestos
para que funcionaran en la frontera y lo
que más jugó fue la disposición de ambos
lados para que se reanude el comercio
entre ambos países recordemos que las
relaciones diplomáticas entre venezuela
y colombia se rompieron en el año 2019
pero justamente este viernes se cumplen
siete años del cierre de los pasos
fronterizos
la justicia estadounidense decidirá si
da a conocer las razones por las cuales
se autorizó el allanamiento a la
residencia del expresidente donald trump
en florida el caso ha enfrentado a
fiscales federales con medios de
comunicación que insisten en que se
revelen dichas razones alegando interés
público sin embargo el magistrado que
escuchó los argumentos a favor y en
contra dice que espera tener una versión
editada y sin datos sensibles sobre la
investigación para decidir si puede
darla a conocer
hadi matar el hombre que atacó al
escritor salman rushdie compareció ante
el tribunal de la ciudad de nueva york
el hombre ya había sido acusado de un
cargo de intento de asesinato y un cargo
de asalto en segundo grado
su abogado intentó sin éxito persuadir
al juez para que lo pusiera en libertad
mientras esperaba el juicio la fiscalía
está considerando investigarlo por
posibles crímenes de odio vestido con un
uniforme blanco y negro hadi matar de 24
años permaneció en silencio en su
comparecencia ante el tribunal el jueves
nuevamente se declaró no culpable
hablando fuera del juzgado el fiscal del
distrito jason chen hizo una
actualización sobre la situación del
caso
la forma en que el estatuto de crimen de
odio funciona en el estado de nueva york
es que aumenta sirve como un dispositivo
de intensificación para que ya sabes
digamos un delito de nivel ve ahora
pueda subir un escalón así que estamos
viviendo eso elegimos no acusarlo por
razones que es importante para nosotros
ir con los hechos y la ley y esa es
nuestra decisión por ahora
a
raya y fue atacado mientras estaba en el
escenario de un evento literario en el
estado de nueva york el pasado viernes
sufriendo graves heridas matar fue
detenido en el lugar de los hechos el
miércoles declaró al new york post que
no le gustaba rushdie que según él había
atacado al islam todo ello mientras
admitía que sólo había leído dos páginas
de su controvertida novela 'los versos
satánicos' también se mostró sorprendido
de que la autor hubiera sobrevivido al
ataque comentando la entrevista el
fiscal se me dijo que podría ser usada
en el caso por su parte el abogado deja
de matar pidió al juez impedir que los
periodistas traten de ponerse en
contacto con su cliente fuera de la sala
increpó a una multitud de ellos
de nuevo la orden del juez julio hoy fue
no hablar de ninguno de los detalles de
este caso no voy a hacerlo no voy a
discutirlo
y ustedes escucharon mis argumentos en
la corte no voy a hacer ningún
comentario adicional en este momento
máttar nació y creció en eeuu pero tiene
raíces familiares en el sur del líbano
su próxima comparecencia ante el
tribunal está prevista para septiembre
en paraguay el vicepresidente hugo
velázquez anunció que seguirá en su
cargo tras haber anunciado su renuncia
la semana pasada el movimiento llegó
luego de una acusación de presuntos
actos delictivos entre ellos
señalamientos por corrupciones de eeuu
en las que se afirmó que la decisión de
no renunciar llegará después de que la
fiscalidad paraguaya le asegurara que no
hay ninguna degustación en su contra
según velázquez el presidente mario abdo
benítez ya aceptó su nueva decisión
y una nueva encuesta en brasil sigue
ubicando al ex presidente luiz inácio
lula da silva como el más opcionado a
ganar la presidencia en las elecciones
de octubre de acuerdo con la
encuestadora datafolha lula recibió un
47% de apoyo de los votantes frente al
32% del presidente ayer personaron lo
que mostró un leve incremento para el
mandatario que se ubicaba en un 29 por
ciento en julio los datos también
muestran que en una posible segunda
vuelta entre los dos candidatos lula
regresaría al cargo con el 54% de los
votos frente al 37 por ciento de
evolucionando
el derecho a la memoria está consagrado
en el borrador de la nueva constitución
chilena el artículo busca que haya
esclarecimiento de los crímenes de lesa
humanidad y que los delitos de
desaparición forzada no prescriban para
ser aprobada la constitución deberá
primero pasar por un plebiscito el
próximo 4 de septiembre
la memoria como un derecho es lo que
busca consagrar la nueva constitución
chilena el estado garantiza el derecho a
la memoria y su relación con las
garantías de no repetición y los
derechos a la verdad justicia y
reparación integral el derecho de la
memoria es muy importante para que las
nuevas generaciones
no olviden sepan todo lo que ocurrió en
todos los lugares terribles la época de
dictadura un país sin memoria no puede
construir nada la única forma que
nosotros podemos reivindicar a nuestras
familiares a nuestros familiares
y a los que sobrevivimos a la dictadura
cívico-militar
es recordando es diciendo esto pasó esto
es parte de la memoria nuestra además la
desaparición forzada una práctica
durante la dictadura pinochetista entre
los años 1973 y 1990 no tendrá ni
prescripción y amnistía de ser aprobado
el texto en chile según el director del
parque por la paz existen unos 1600
lugares donde uno y violaciones de
derechos humanos pero su corporación no
tiene financiamiento tiene hemos
constituido como corporaciones privadas
que buscamos fondos a partir de
proyectos y algunos financiamientos que
podamos conseguir eso no está
garantizado por parte del estado y
nosotros entendemos y por eso digamos
que fuera incluido en la nueva
constitución el deber de recordarlo
el artículo pasó con 111 votos a favor
de la convención constitucional que
presentó el borrador de la carta magna
aunque también se contemplan derechos
sociales cambio del régimen pensional o
derecho a la educación gratuita la
constitución deberá ser refrendada en un
plebiscito el 4 de septiembre
hasta que este informativo en las 24
gracias por acompañarnos continúen con
toda nuestra programación
[Música]